in this video i'm going to show you
exactly how to create your own house
floor plan design in five easy steps
let's go all right so today we're
starting with arcade 25 and i'm using
one of my personal templates you can use
any template you want everything i show
you today is going to be exactly the
same before we start we want to come
across to our project map click on that
little 3d house come down to our ground
floor and double click so we know we're
working on an actual floor plate next
we're only really focusing about the
actual floor plan design itself so we
want to focus with the wall tool in the
top left hand corner you're going to
find a plain box that is your wall tool
it is going to be on any layer you need
to we're not focusing on layers we're
not going in depth today this is
literally just to get you a floor plan
and then at the top here as well you're
going to have all your different types
of brick and stud walls as well pick
anything you want again it is not
important for the sake of this tutorial
by holding the scroll wheel and dragging
left and right you can actually pan
across so we're going to start somewhere
over here on the blank side of the
screen if we're designing a floor plan
all you want to do is click once while
you have that wall selected hold shift
to keep that wall dead straight click
again to keep creating some sort of
floor plan so for the purposes of this
that's going to be my floor plan my
original box idea and you can replicate
that same idea for anything that you
want so if you want to come back to your
wall tool and click once more click
again to actually create your rooms
inside your rooms you can keep clicking
as many times as you want literally just
to start creating some sort of floor
plan in here that resembles what you're
trying to design or what you're trying
to communicate to somebody next you
might be thinking that floor plan may be
huge maybe tiny i have absolutely no
idea how do we get further how do we
concentrate on the actual dimensions
what do we actually know about this
floor plan so if we come down to our
dimension tool underneath document click
on that and then again click on one of
our outside walls and both outside walls
we're going to see that's 16 meters wide
that there is 16 meters wide so i've
made a relatively good block now in this
instance these dimensions don't matter
to me because it's just a tutorial to
showcase what we want to do but if i was
to select this outside wall because i
wanted that to be exactly 16 meters i
could either click on that end node come
down to this drag tool or by clicking
escape to get out of that menu i could
press ctrl d
and drag that across type in 105 to move
it 105 millimeters across a quick little
interlude if you need any assistance
designing floor plans or anything
architectural make sure you check out
the links below next we need to focus on
our doors and our windows so they're two
different tools you have your door
object over here and you have your
window object over here if we want to go
to our door tool click on the door at
the top
and
then simply type in dol archicad will
produce a million or one different door
options that we can select from that we
can edit from that we can use in a
million different ways so if i simply
click on door 25 style i can change my
style let's keep it as one let's keep it
as 900 click ok
locate roughly where i want my door
click ok
click again and i can start placing my
doors into my project
as i see fit now again this isn't about
actually using arcade properly this is
just about
showing you how to get a floor plan and
an idea on paper very very quickly it
isn't about documenting anything in
detail so all we're really looking to
showcase is how we can get a floor plan
together in a very simple process the
same process for windows is we come
across to our window tool we click up
the top to our windows settings and we
type in window which allows archicad to
showcase us all the different styles of
windows that they have automatically
generated for us
so we can go through any of these
windows select them as we see fit or we
can create our own window like before
let's just say we want to use this
window
here and here and then we want to use a
different window let's say this one over
here
for this wall
and this wall and we're going to repeat
that process a couple times now last but
not least what we're going to need to do
is actually show some objects inside and
potentially some text so text is the
easy one we can simply type drag and
let's call this mask bedroom click ok
now we know that is our master bedroom i
can then again repeat that and go
living bed to bath and entry
so now i have some tags everywhere that
might be useful to me might not be but
that's how we create our tags next we go
into our object tool
click on the object at the top let's say
we're searching for a toilet so we
simply type in toilet wc 25 is more than
enough for us right now so we just
simply come in down click on our toilet
anywhere in the project command d or
control d lets you move it control
command e lets you rotate it while
holding shift allows you to rotate it at
perfectly 90 degrees i can replicate
that same process over here with this
other toilet we can simply repeat that
step for whatever we need so let's say
now we need a shower we can type in
shower cabin click ok
drop it into our project place it where
we believe it should go repeat that step
again let's say we want a new bathtub a
freestanding bath like that could fit
perfectly over here now let's say we
need a little bit more furniture in this
floor plan for example we're in a bed so
the process is the same for everything
that we're looking for we're typing in
bed we're getting our bed we can drop it
into our project let's say now we need a
sofa for our actual living areas as well
we can continue to repeat that same
process over and over again for as many
objects as we need regardless of what
we're looking for archicad probably has
something resembling what we need so
unless you're really trying to
specifically create a 3d image you can
most likely
simply just use whatever object archicad
has to be able to actually
create what you're looking for so now we
have our master bedroom our bathrooms
little bits and pieces in between we
know how big our floor plan is we know
where our doors are we know where our
windows are we know
basically everything there is to know
about archicad to be able to produce
something very quickly something very
easily and something that you can convey
to somebody else and that's it my name's
david thomach i'll see you next time